welcome back to CBS this morning
Wisconsin holds a presidential primary
today despite Democrats attempts to
delay it you can expect that social
distancing will be affected all the
polling stations but the state's
Democratic governor says Republicans are
forcing people to choose between their
health and their right to vote political
correspondent ed O'Keefe joins us from
Washington with more on this story and I
guess the question is why not just
postpone it yeah good morning look it's
not just a presidential primary today
there are local elections and a
competitive state Supreme Court race
also on the ballot and the fight going
on in this key battleground state could
actually be a preview of court fights
between Democrats and Republicans in the
coming months as voting continues amid
the pandemic Wisconsin is in the midst
of a stay at home order and the
Democratic governor Tony Evers had
called on the republican-led legislature
to reschedule today's elections until
June for safety reasons but GOP leaders
and eventually the state Supreme Court
refused late last night the US Supreme
Court also waited in striking down a
plan to allow absentee ballots to be
accepted through next Monday they must
be put in the mail by today but state
officials won't release the results of
today's elections until Monday April
13th all four of the courts top liberal
members dissent egde of Justice Ruth
Bader Ginsburg said voters will either
quote have to brave the polls
endangering their own and others safety
or they will lose their right to vote
senator Bernie Sanders of course is on
the ballots and they called this
decision potentially deadly but he
trails former Vice President Joe Biden
by a wide margin in polling in Wisconsin
and in the delegate race and yet there
are no signs that he plans to drop out
Tony all right thank you very much